all right i want to start today with a
little data some numbers one often
repeated claim about gun violence in the
united states is
the gun violence is a problem in
so-called democrat cities
with the strictest gun laws in the
country and there's sort of two claims
that the right loves to make that are
implicit in that one the problems with
gun violence are in places that try to
restrict guns meaning restrictive gun
laws increase violence and murder
and the second claim is the most violent
places are the places run by democrats
i put together data in a few different
ways and we're going to look at it but
the most important i mean before even
looking at the data one of the things
you have to remember is that in general
there is more crime in more densely
populated areas the more densely
populated areas
tend to be places where people on the
left tend to live
but the truth is that the more violent
cities and the least violent cities are
all mostly run by democrats because
democrats prefer to live in cities
whereas republicans prefer to live in
rural areas generally speaking so
one of the things you first have to
think about is
what does the country look like before
we even can make any causal uh
claims
but that being said
let's take a look at some of this data
so what i did was i took the
where am i here i took the here we go
i took the most uh the 65
um cities with the highest murder rates
in the country and that's along the left
and you can find this data and uh those
are the cities that i have listed and
then we looked at who is the mayor of
those cities and are they a democrat or
a republican and then at the county
level was that a biden county or a trump
county in 2020 and then at the state
level was that a trump state or a biden
state in 2020. now i have to tell you
even doing this is a little fraught
because there are certain states
virginia a bunch of these cities are in
virginia in 2020 biden won but sometimes
republicans win virginia so some of
these states are question marks ohio is
a state that sometimes flips florida is
a state that sometimes slips but there's
a trend here that is very clear
um the
cities with the most uh the highest
murder rates
at the city level it's mostly democratic
mayors now we would expect that that
makes perfect sense cities tend to be
run by democrats if we looked at a list
of the cities with the least gun
violence you would also see that they're
mostly run by democrats
cities often make up the entire county
in which they are or close to it in new
york city actually there's
the city includes multiple counties uh
brooklyn's and kings county whereas
manhattan okay we've some people sort of
understand that but generally speaking
you would assume that the county would
be similar to the city in that
cities and counties often are the same
size or very close to it and most of the
counties that contain these cities were
biden counties well is that a big
revelation about gun violence not really
because if you look at the entire map of
the united states
by county we know that cities tend to
vote for democrats and all the other
counties tend to vote for republicans
typically so
cities on the most dangerous list and
cities on the least dangerous list would
all be um on the
uh
on would be run by would be democratic
counties and then lastly you look at the
state level and when you look at the
state level you see that there's a lot
of red there a lot a lot a lot of red
trump
states that trump won
and when we want to draw a causal
relationship one of the questions we
have to ask
is whether gun policy tends to be set at
the city county or state level
and it's mostly at the state level so
if we understand
most of the murders will be where there
is more population density
but the gun laws are mostly going to be
set at the state level
you have to ask well does saint louis
have a lot of murders because the mayor
is a democrat
or because it's a red state with red
state gun laws i'm not pretending that
the answer in all cases is one or the
other
but if we understand
that it's mostly states that determine
gun policy although there are some
cities that will go above and beyond
that's absolutely the case and we
understand that at the base rate
democrats tend to live more in cities
than republicans and we understand that
even if you're in chicago chicago's gun
laws if you can drive into indiana at
the end of the day don't really impact
your ability to get a gun very much
unless there's a cohesive effort
this repeated talking point of gun
violence is a democrat city problem
very quickly falls apart now i'm totally
open
to exploring other explanations let me
give you another one
we can also accurately say gun violence
seems to be a red state problem
but there as well i'm willing to say
maybe access to mental health is part of
it we've got to deal with the guns but
maybe mental health is part of it but
it's the red states that fund mental
health services
less than blue states we looked at that
earlier this week it's the red states
like texas that have governors like greg
abbott who recently voted against more
funding for mental health treatment so i
say let's look at all of these things
but we have to include guns in that and
we have to understand
democrat city problem
is not accurate and there's no
particular reason to look at cities
rather than states when you look at
states it's a red state problem
if you look at cities it's a democrat
problem only in the sense that most
cities are run by democrats the really
safe ones and the unsafe ones so i think
you get the picture we're going to
continue following up on this
there is major news coming out of the
house of representatives nancy pelosi
now says that the house of
representatives is indeed going to move
forward on an assault weapons ban there
was previously an assault weapons ban
that ran from 1994 to 2004 in the united
states and we will talk about that in a
moment speaker of the house nancy pelosi
says house democrats will soon consider
legislation banning military-style quote
assault weapons marking the most
aggressive response from congress to
date following last week's shooting
massacre at a texas elementary school
house democratic leaders have already
scheduled to vote next week on so-called
red flag legislation designed to keep
weapons from potentially violent people
the house judiciary committee is meeting
in an emergency session to mark up a
slate of eight additional anti-gun
violence bills including proposals to
ban high-capacity magazines and raise
the age for purchasing certain
semi-automatic rifles i am in favor of
all of this and also recognize that it
is not enough and we're going to get
back to that now on the question of
whether mass shootings
went down during the assault weapons ban
and then went back up after it has been
examined by politifact and it has been
found to be mostly true joe biden said
when we passed the assault weapons ban
mass shootings went down when the law
expired mass shootings tripled
politifact has ruled that is mostly true
um
their explanation is let me find it here
there are numbers that back biden up a
2019 study out of nyu school of medicine
found mass shooting deaths involving
assault weapons fell slightly in the
decade of the federal assault weapon ban
and then rose dramatically in the decade
that followed
while other researchers said the decline
was too small to draw firm conclusions
there's no debate that the pace and
deadliness of shootings went up after
the ban ended beyond assault weapons
more recent work points to the threat
posed by large capacity magazines which
the 1994 law also restricted that is
also a factor with the same guns but
without the large capacity magazines you
would also see less less death so
if you go back to last week i had my
segment where i laid out it was either
10 or 11 specific ideas on gun safety
and in that list i included
limiting certain firearms to 25 plus
some some are saying 21 plus i say 25
plus requiring mandatory gun insurance
requiring more extensive training and
re-licensing a mandatory waiting period
uh of of course reducing the ability to
have the high capacity magazines a
mandatory initial and periodic mental
health evaluations
requiring two to three letters from
adults in the community
saying i have no concerns about this
individual under age 25 having firearms
i gave a long list but we actually need
to do more than that and of course
republicans are going to oppose this i
say that democrats in conjunction with
this bill to ban assault weapons again
which will it pass in the senate
probably not quite frankly unfortunately
they should
call the bluff of the republicans saying
well this is a mental health issue
propose mental health legislation as
well
now of course part of that is red flag
laws which would prevent individuals
flagged for concerning behavior um and
and diagnoses from it would prevent them
from getting weapons but
do something more significant require
require
an initial
mental health eval as well as periodic
ones now i know a lot of people have
raised the question
let's say you do that david
what are you looking for is it just
a psychiatrist meets with everybody
and then
evaluates for what what conditions
prevent you from getting a gun how does
anxiety compare with borderline
personality disorder compare with if
you've had a psychotic episode well
you've got to figure that out the fact
that it's complicated can't be a reason
not to do it i concede it's complicated
but it absolutely needs to be done
if all of these things were in place
when it came to the shooter in texas
can't buy the weapons he bought because
he's under age 25
even to get a handgun needs to have
letters from the community supposedly
members in the community were already
some were already concerned about this
individual limits on high-capacity
magazines waiting period um
mandatory insurance which would have
made it more expensive and maybe
dissuaded although he reportedly spent a
bunch of money on the guns
those things at least had the chance the
chance of impacting that individual's
ability to get those firearms
and those bullets and to kill as many
people could he have ended up killing
five
with a couple handguns yes
absolutely
but as tragic as those five deaths would
be
would we prefer five instead of 20 i
mean i would
i would so i would like to see democrats
not only push for the assault weapons
ban propose some mental health
legislation to republicans including
increased funding as well
at the state level they don't want it
many states didn't even do the medicare
the medicaid expansion but that was part
of obamacare which would have increased
access as well so make them put up or
shut up make them go on record as
opposing the mental health legislation
they're the ones claiming that's the
first thing to look at we'll look at it
but also look at guns and we've got to
look at a lot of other things i am sure
i will get many questions on this topic
on our upcoming town hall that will be
tuesday june 14th at 6 pm eastern
streaming live on the pacman live
youtube channel that's the other youtube
channel make sure you're subscribed
there for free and i look forward to
speaking to lots of you then
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a community
supported independent media program you
can sign up at
joinpackman.com and in fact i encourage
you to do so you can use the new coupon
code big voting 22 big voting 22
to get a massive discount
and also
to do a really great thing supporting
independent media joinpakman.com is the
place to do it let's hear from some
people in the audience we take calls on
the friday show via discord
davidpakman.com slash discord let's
start today with nevin from tennessee
nevin welcome to the show what's on your
mind today
uh hey david i had two questions
first there's something there's
something that just banged in the
background you said you have two
questions
yes yes
okay
okay so
firstly do you think that progressive
economic reforms such as universal
health care tuition forgiveness etc
can be accomplished without like a big
economic depression such as with the new
deal during fdr
so you you said can can we avoid an
economic depression through
programs like the new deal
yes like universal health care for a
nice program like stuff like that yeah i
mean generally speaking government
spending that is carefully thought
uh carefully conceived
to be economically stimulative through
what we call demand side stimulus is a
good way to both do good things for the
people and also to help the economy that
the devil is in the details of the
programs and the spending
okay and
i'd also
like to ask you um what can southern
liberals like myself do
did you say for the progressive cause
yes
well get involved in local races at some
level even in southern red states
is there an opportunity to replace a
right-wing state represents senator with
someone more progressive is there an
opportunity to get involved in a school
board
there's lots of local opportunities and
also you can still phone bank for any
race across the country that you want so
like imagine that you're in alabama and
there's no likely democratic senate
challenger in alabama you can phone bank
for fetterman in pennsylvania right or
you can whatever so there's there's no
shortage of ways to get involved
yeah
that's all thanks for taking my call
nevin i have to ask where are you
calling from the noise in the background
is is wild
i'm on a bus ride oh you're on a bus
right now
yeah do people around you know you're on
the david pakman
show uh they probably don't know what it
is they don't know fair all right nevin
thank you for the call
uh you're welcome all right
nevin from oh thank you nevin from a bus
in tennessee that is something else
i don't know that we've ever had a call
from a bus necessarily
let's go next to ernest from missouri
ernest welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
uh hi david um i wanted to kind of
preface my question by saying i love the
way you engage with people who's
you don't necessarily agree with
um that's a skill i think that's lost uh
in the modern political debate or at
least is slipping away from us
oh you're welcome what are your what are
some things you think we can do to like
encourage people to engage in more civil
debates and uh kind of to broaden that
out to get away from like the talking
point
and more on the issues at hand you know
my view on this shifts over time
one of the things i've been trying
recently
is kind of putting it out there and you
i people who have seen my appearances on
some places recently like the michael
knowles show and trigonometry might have
noticed that i did this i say up front
hey dude are we on the same page that we
want to have a good faith debate and
we're not trying to do gotchas but we're
trying to really solve problems or find
shared understanding
even if the other person
doesn't have any plan to do that usually
they'll at least say that that's their
goal and then you can use that as
something to point back to and say hey
listen let's let's skip the talking
points we both said we wanted a good
faith conversation and we want to try to
find some answers
can't we just agree that x and it's sort
of a cheap rhetorical tool
but it might actually predispose people
to maybe come in with with a slightly
better attitude you know if you asked me
a year ago i might have had some
different technique that i was trying at
the time
another tool that can be useful
is
starting with where we agree so you know
you could have a very contentious issue
like
i don't know abortion or something like
that but you could first start with well
what what do we agree on we we agree
that murder is bad uh certainly on all
the instances where we agree as to what
murder is
we agree that we want uh people's
ability to
determine the best course for their life
is something that should be priority you
know you lay out all of these areas of
agreement and this can often kind of
really narrow the scope of the
disagreement in a way that it seems more
manageable so that's another idea but
this is a really big topic and my if you
ask me in six months i might have a
different perspective
right um and so if you don't mind i kind
of had a follow-up yeah please which is
what i think is the more relevant thing
and i kind of wanted to frame that
because you do do an excellent job of
like laying that out
so how do we uh how do we use this to
engage with like these institutions that
control us
and create tautologies
that we can kind of break down and see
are just objectively false
that yet they stick to them and then
even you know utilize other legal means
and like means of power
to uh to keep them
to keep
kind of these these things true like
i'll use that in quotes i see that as a
really different question that's less
about convincing any individual with the
tools i mentioned
that's really more about how can just
the people
get
um
substantive access to those institutions
where often the access is reserved for
corporations and high-powered donors so
that's a more systemic question to me
than one about what are like the the
rhetorical tools that might be used
okay
all right
well thank you very much i appreciate it
i i think that's the truth the way truth
is framed i think is one of the most
important things one of the most
important discussions today and so
that's why i uh wanted to hit on that
and thank you so much for answering my
question my pleasure it was a great
question and a very very important topic
let's try our friend eric from cancun
eric how are things in beautiful sunny
humid cancun mexico today
um hi david right now we have a storm
and as you can see my topic is that i
want to do an encore about some topics i
already said oh beautiful one would be
and would be when i said about the
[Music]
toxic fandoms about icons
i said then and they made a song stand
to
point out how toxic venom is
what i'm left out to say is that there's
times that the artists are blamed for
the when bad people do
bad stuff and they blame the artist
because thinking that they're being
manipulated for that
as saying that they're blaming video
games for the shootout that happened
right now and also that it would be
unfair to blame jd salinger that they
killed john lennon
um uh eric do you think that the johnny
depp amber heard trial
is an example of toxic fandom
empire would be because usually they
blame men for the abuse of domestic and
in the house but i believe that john is
innocent in this time but this would be
more like when they were blaming michael
jackson for being a pedophile but then
the kid who sued him confessed that it
was a sad idea to lie about it
wow i'm not super familiar with that
case that that's amazing eric what else
is on your mind today i know you always
have a big agenda
awesome when i mentioned about occam's
racer then i told you that right-wingers
and conspiracy theories want to be like
james bond but they barely make it to
austin powers
and the point would be that aside them
from wanting to be a super spy the thing
is that they would believe in those
things because one of their biggest
fears is another is admitting that they
were wrong but there would be times that
i wish to be wrong when i know something
bad is gonna happen sometimes would be
when i knew that daenerys would become
her dad and would burn
king's landing awesome when
i woke with the staff cybil and also
when sugo would betray katara
right also when he was going to die to
save the multiverse from thanos
well eric you've really said it all i
only understand about 15 of it but it's
such a pleasure to hear from you and i
hope you're doing well
um one more one last one okay
and
so there would be a part when i say the
politician would be based their policies
and cartoons
and if you'll remember grandpa cozart
wouldn't put himself as aaron [ __ ]
from attack on titan and kill joe biden
as he colossal titan i do remember that
yeah paul gosar published this uh
cartoon of him like appearing to kill
kill biden and or aoc i think
there will be spoilers in the fourth and
and becomes a titan and then he wants to
use his powers to kill the all the
titans to save humanity from being eaten
by them but in the fourth season he
becomes a sociopath because he blames
the neighbor kingdom from creating the
titans and he kills 80 percent of the
population so maybe it will fit to
his kind of party of being genocidals
well eric you've said it all uh i really
appreciate your call okay
thank you and be good all right say hi
to fern cousin for me oh of course
farron absolutely i will say hi to
farren there is eric from cancun with
another powerful
declaration of all kinds let's go next
to taylor from atlanta georgia taylor
welcome to the program
hey david how's it going it's going well
hey good talk to you
likewise uh
i wanted to
just kind of bring up a thought
or opinion and get your thoughts on it
okay uh i guess
suggest the the culpability of the nra
is maybe a little bit more i mean sorry
a little bit less than what we're giving
it okay and i don't mean they i don't
mean their inaction you know isn't uh
maddening but
um
i think these issues with the guns
and like i don't think the gun lobby has
enough
as much power as we're saying they do
okay what and so why do you on what
particular issue so give like
be a little more specific
so just lobbying the you know the
senators and congress
to
completely
so we're losing we're losing your audio
it's starting to get all all chopped up
i mean listen one of the things that i
think is important to consider is
most democrats and republicans want
total universal background checks
eliminating all loopholes to get around
it the nra is against that and the nra
directly funds
many of the elected officials
who are also against it so i think it
would be natural to be wondering
what is the effect of those donations it
seems natural to ask that question and
it seems the effect is probably some
i i agree but i'm saying there's
potentially other
factors at play i think there's a large
uh
concerted group of religious
fundamentalists yes that have in a way
buried themselves into politics
and so when i see people like ted cruz
on stage
i essentially
don't see him saying like hey i'm on the
nra side he's saying don't vote me out
like don't replace me because
these people have come up with ways that
they're politically successful in that
they've done the math you need you have
a given percentage of people that vote
republican given percent that vote
democrat and so all they need to do is
address
the remaining three percent
right
that i don't disagree with that and and
oftentimes uh
the appeal to that slice it might be
bigger than three percent but the appeal
to that slice is based on a number of
wedge issues that are not even that
important to the bulk of the voters that
regularly vote one way or the other
that's that's the disturbing part
exactly exactly yeah
all right well thank you for the call i
appreciate your insights
thanks all right
why don't we speak next to um
you know there's just so many people
waiting today what if we speak to ryan
from austin ryan from austin you're on
the air
hey david thanks for taking my call my
pleasure i just had a quick question uh
what do you think the democrats
messaging should be going into the
upcoming midterms uh giving the current
political landscape do you think that
gun control and abortion rights are
gonna be winning issues in november or
do you think we should have a more like
broad progressive message you know 99 of
the time i would be saying abortion and
gun rights are not winning issues and it
should be primarily an economic message
we are in a unique situation where i'm
actually wondering
maybe the focus should be on the right's
determined uh inaction
on gun issues
and
its support of the overturning of roe v
wade by the supreme court which is very
unpopular with the american public and i
would almost never say this every
election i've covered i have not not
said this
don't talk about guns don't talk about
abortion
this particular time the public seems so
repulsed with what's going on with those
two issues
what the hell maybe it is a good
strategy this november
yeah i agree um the only thing i worry
about is i wonder if that public
propulsion is gonna
continue to be there in november or if
it's gonna fly away it's still five
months from now and who knows what will
happen in the next five months that's my
hesitation as well but i think compared
to other elections it actually might be
a winning message this time around i
don't know and listen you know what
otherwise it's not like it was looking
that great for democrats anyway so i
don't know that i have a better idea for
them yeah exactly what the hell may as
well run on it yeah
all right well thank you so much okay
thanks for the call uh we're going to
keep taking calls after a very short
break so please don't hang up i will get
right back to the phones uh in a moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow okay let's get back to
people waiting to chat on discord
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go
next to our friend issa from london issa
welcome back to the program
hey david how's it going it's going well
um you know i was thinking that loads of
gun owners in the us
they say that one of the reasons they
want to own weapons
is to protect themselves from an overly
intrusive government yes um like a
tyrannical government um so i'm not i
don't know too much about this but i was
wondering uh if say if the us government
decided to
like you know launch an attack on its
population wouldn't they use military
technology that
that would be it would be meaningless to
use rifles against that kind of stuff
that's my opinion as well yeah and this
has been brought up before which is
uh if the
you know and it's funny because
many of the same people that say that
love having the biggest most powerful
military so they simultaneously are like
we need our military to have all the
best most powerful stuff
and also if it becomes tyrannical
we need to have our assault rifles to
protect ourselves which number one
wouldn't really even be useful because
the government has such overwhelming
force but also if you suspect that that
may happen with the government why would
you want them to have such a powerful
army like it's both idiotic and also
contradictory it doesn't make any sense
yeah yeah good point i agree i i i think
it's um
it's a bit odd how uh
loads of
american gun owners
uh feel like uh their sense of freedom
is is tied into being able to own
firearms yes and they're not only their
sense of freedom their sense of identity
yeah
yeah
all right well thank you very much for
the call
thank you all right there's issa from
london always great
to hear from our friends on the other
side of the pond let's go next to john
from ohio welcome john
hi david can hear me yes i can
okay great um yeah i would also like to
talk about uh the whole gun issue
i was speaking to my mom about this and
she grew up in the in the 70s and she
told me
you know she never
uh grew up having to experience all of
this
all these uh you know mass shootings and
gun violence yeah um i guess my question
is um do you think
i guess can you think of anything that
has happened between that time and now
that has
really caused this epidemic to
ramp up i guess maybe besides the number
of guns in our society
well that's a big thing but in addition
to that also just gun culture here in
the united states guns have become the
identity of many
they have become a valid way to solve
problems for too many people
and that's that's a factor as well i
mean it's both the ready availability of
firearms
and uh
the the flooding of the market with them
and the ease with which they can be
obtained
but also the very toxic and destructive
culture around guns it's both
yeah i agree
uh i mean i think
i guess
it almost seems like we're a society
that just
seems to glorify
violence
and i guess maybe that's
i guess one other reason to maybe why we
see
uh you know the mass shooting epidemic
just ramping up so much in our country
yeah maybe to some degree i mean the
thing is generally speaking the
glorification of violence starts to get
into sort of like it's violent video
games that are the cause and i i'm a
little bit hesitant so i don't know that
i would necessarily use those terms i
like to call it a culture in which guns
are seen as ways to solve problems that
shouldn't involve guns and that's just a
cultural issue that needs to be changed
right and i guess by
i guess a culture that glorifies
violence i guess
what i mean is uh it seems to be like
maybe people nowadays are more
likely to be uh you know nasty to each
other or
uh be physically violent with each other
and i guess you know part of that is
as you said the idea that
guns are i guess an avenue to solve
problems yes absolutely it's a disaster
quite frankly
yeah i agree well thank you for the uh
thank you for taking my call david my
pleasure thank you for calling in
lots of folks understandably concerned
about what's going on with guns that
makes sense let's go to roy from south
jersey next welcome roy
hi david hi
so i was wondering um you know biden
said that he would get the equality act
passed within his first hundred days
that didn't happen
uh chuck schumer said he'd bring it to
the floor in june pride month last year
that didn't happen so
do you think it's ever going to happen
uh no probably not
i mean if i'm totally honest with you i
just i just don't see it happening
anytime soon particularly now
with what's going on with the shootings
ukraine's still going on midterms coming
up i think now senate's on some kind of
break or was on a break i i i don't see
it i don't see it happening
that's unfortunate now i had another
question um
my both my parents think that the
election was stolen but for various
reasons my mom as you say her mind is
mayonnaise that she thinks the q anon
and
trump won every state
she thinks trump won every state
yes even california
that's correct wow
yep now my dad thinks oh well you know
in pennsylvania they changed the rules
for drop boxes and you know stuff like
that so that's why it's stolen right
which is more dangerous do you think
uh
hmm
well i don't know that the ideas
themselves are necessarily more or less
dangerous it's sort of what people do
with them so i i don't know that i'm
like super crystal clear on it do you
knowing the two of them do you have a
sense of which is more dangerous
i mean i you know my dad's arguments
make more sense to people even though
they don't make sense okay obviously the
legislators can change the rules to the
elections
that's simple but yeah you know i mean
on paper yes my moms look more more
crazy but my dad seemed to convince more
people so that's you know where i'm
struggling with that that's a common
that's a common thing we've talked about
before
which is
what's worse
a really crazy politician
who can't get anything done but their
ideas are more dangerous versus a
marginally less crazy politician
who
is is less dangerous in their ideas
but might actually be able to make some
of their ideas a reality it's sort it's
sort of a similar thing and i think it's
you got to take it on a case-by-case
basis i don't think the the presence of
large swaths of americans believing
either of the things your parents
believe is particularly good let's put
it that way
that's fair yeah no now one last thing
did you see the the trailer for the
winnie the pooh horror movie no is that
even a thing i've never even heard that
there was a winnie the pooh horror movie
it came out uh recently that this is
happening uh disney lost the rights to
it because some intern forgot to renew
the lease or whatever and uh some guy
picked it up and he's making a horror
movie and it looks terrible but i'm
gonna see it okay wow very good hey
listen one other thing about your
parents
are do either of them have delusional
beliefs about anything other than the
election or is it compartmentalized only
to the election
oh i mean my dad you know he um he's all
right you know he he jokes around a bit
but my mom yeah she's
she's a lunatic on on many fronts oh
like what what other what else does she
believe that she'll mention
well you know she thinks that you know
you can just cure uh
a scratch with just you know healing and
thinking and instead of you know getting
medical advice and whatever okay she
thinks that she cured cancer by you know
wishing it away
so you know she's i'm worried because
you know she smokes a lot and i think
she's going to get lung cancer and then
she's not going to get treatment because
she thinks she can just do this and then
she's going to die you know wait now roy
she i'm guessing you mean she thinks she
cured someone else's cancer with prayer
no her own i don't i don't think she did
have cancer at all so
wait wait oh hold on wait let me
so
you're not even sure your mom had cancer
but she believes she had it and cured it
with prayer
that's correct but she was never
diagnosed with cancer
that is correct wow and so why did she
believe she had cancer
uh she had like a lump on her arm or
something and then she prayed and it
went away
yeah
do you think it might have just been
like a cyst or something
it's definitely possible wow wow i feel
really bad for you roy that sounds like
a really tough situation how old a guy
are you i am 23 24 in the week okay and
are you like out of the home or do you
live with these parents you're
describing
i live with my dad my mom's uh separated
got it got it okay wow well listen roy
you've got you've got your hands full
yeah yeah yeah well i appreciate you
sharing your story
thank you all right there's roy wow that
is that is full on that is weaponized
when we talk about weaponized beliefs
that's really what we're talking about
that is uh
that is something
all right let's go next to um isaac from
wyoming isaac welcome
hi can you hear me yes i can
all right uh i just wanted to talk about
the cynthia loomis speech uh i know this
happened a couple weeks ago yeah so for
people who don't know let me catch them
up if i can just so everybody knows
cynthia loomis wyoming senator spoke at
the commencement ceremony of university
of wyoming and uh she she brought up you
know she was sort of anti-trans in the
speech and we talked about it
right and you had mentioned in the
beginning of the video that you didn't
know why she would go to a sort of
transphobic direction
so i kind of wanted to just give my
opinion on that okay
i think
on a national level
it was seen as loomis making a stupid
comment
and
yes students booed when she made the
comment about people denying quote
scientific facts about there being two
sexes
um
my thought is this was a well thought
out
and calculated scandal that was uh a
very safe move for her
because these are university of wyoming
graduates many of whom aren't from
wyoming and will move out of state after
graduating she's not worried about their
vote
it's clear to me
that loomis made this con knowing it
would score points with her base
uh while undermining higher education
which i believe the gop is very much
against because they they don't want the
working-class people to be educated
absolutely that's all true
uh loomis
knew
that it would be controversial
and she would be in headlines
um and that the largely uneducated
religious base of wyoming would see it
so she would score points with her base
because now she's seen as exposing
higher education for brainwashing people
into
liberal wokeness right
yeah wyoming is interesting i i've never
been but i would like to i mean how how
rural do you is your circumstance do you
live rurally or in one of the cities
so uh
i live in albany county which is where
the university of wyoming is and
i think because
it's it's where the university of
wyoming is
more liberal type
people
tend to
live in that in this area
um
the the other more sort of
liberal area of wyoming would be
around jackson
uh which is you know it's all you know
you got to be really wealthy to live in
jackson but
but i mean in terms of how rural it is
you're you're not in one of these
situations where it's like 20 miles to
the grocery store or anything like that
no no no no
like uh with the university of wyoming
it is
you would probably consider it like a
smaller town not not like a large city
but yeah yeah there's grocery stores
there's
movie theaters there's a downtown area
that's really great and
um
lots of towns like that in wyoming it's
not
large largely of
i mean bars a little bit
but yeah
can you get a good bagel in wyoming
um i mean those supermarkets have bagels
oh my goodness okay i feel really bad
for you that is that's that's a bad
answer i mean it's you're not nothing
you're lying
like there's like einstein big old
chicken oh god oh my god i'm gonna have
to let you go okay
okay i feel wow wyoming i feel sorry for
everybody there okay thank you i
appreciate the call uh man that is that
is disturbing
your choices are einstein brothers
and which actually it's not that bad
actually when i was when i was in
arizona recently i got i had no choice
but at the start of a drive i picked up
an einstein brothers bagel it was i
actually wasn't terrible but um and then
your freezer aisle of supermarket bagels
that's that's pretty tough
all right everybody thank you to
everybody who called in we will take
more calls next week we've got our town
hall coming up on june 14th
and i look forward to talking to more
people we'll take a quick break and be
right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
it is friday and it's time for the
mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com if you have something to
say sometimes we'll look at tweets
sometimes we'll look at youtube comments
um could be from anywhere let's get
right into it first one today indeed
does come to us from youtube it's from
john
john says david why won't you talk about
hunter biden's laptop you must support
russia
ukraine and china
david you are our shame well another
unintelligible screed very common to
youtube we've talked about hunter
biden's laptop as a media story probably
a handful of times
and of course i must support russia
and ukraine
and china those are all players on
different sides of the game different
perspectives i'm starting to think that
john may not be fully versed in
geopolitics
based on this message
michael wrote in about the fox news mass
shooting response and says hey david
curious as to how fox news and other
right-wing types could possibly believe
that prayer and church is the answer
when the u.s is 30th worldwide in
percentage of atheists and i know you
know where we rank in the world for mass
shootings i am sick of these people not
having any responsibility for the
nonsense they spew out on a daily basis
it makes me want to quit paying
attention to anything political
hope is gone yet with all of these
things there's always some absurdity
where
all signs point to guns as at least a
major factor that has to be dealt with
oh we don't have enough religion well we
have way more religion than most
countries and we also have way more
shootings so if you want to look at that
correlation it doesn't bode particularly
well for god maybe god just isn't a
factor in this one way or the other and
it's time to actually look at guns i
don't know
just an idea but
mike from atlanta
accurately pointing that out
kristoff wrote in and said can we talk
about the irony that the people who for
the past two years were crying about the
psychological effect that masks would
have on children at schools now want
children to wear ballistic blankets in
case of a shooting and watch their
teacher shoot someone in front of them
yeah the the it's actually multi-layered
and i tweeted about some of these things
on the one hand
the covet masks were
irreparably psychologically traumatizing
to the kids
but wearing you know a bulletproof
backpack
a ballistic blanket and having their
teachers be armed
is supposed to not have a detrimental
psychological impact that obviously
makes no sense but there's also the
hypocrisy when it comes to the teachers
the these are the very teachers that the
right wing has spent the last two years
saying
these are groomers
these are people
perpetuating the psychological abuse by
enforcing mask rules
they're indoctrinators they are
wokesters they are critical race theory
teaching indoctrinators who can't be
trusted
let's give them the ultimate
responsibility of being armed in school
so that they can take out mass shooters
wait you've just said they're not even
capable of choosing the books your kids
should learn from and now you want to
give them guns it's completely absurd
and kristoff accurately points it out
anthony wrote in about the texas school
shooting
and says i thought your piece on the
texas school shooting was quite good
with one exception you didn't have time
to question how hardening the schools
with weapons is going to take care of
the movie theaters and grocery stores
and churches and all the other places
crazy people decide to go and shoot
people for fun how would the right-wing
gun-toting bible-beating right-to-life
or solve that otherwise excellent work
david that's anthony from sac harbor
yeah this is a point that i made during
a live stream but anthony's right i
missed this during during our podcast
segment which is
even if you did all the stuff they want
to do at schools and even if it worked
which of course it's like they don't
want to deal with the gun part but
imagine you did it all
you can't do it at a ton of these other
establishments that have had shootings
you can't do it at the grocery stores
for practical purposes you can't do it
at the movie theaters
it's um
now
it's fair to say we need different
solutions to different problems that's
absolutely fine but again at some point
you've got to deal with the guns you're
not going to have solutions to all these
things without ever dealing with the
guns which is exactly what they want to
do
samuel wrote in about marcus flowers
um okay this this is an important email
samuel says david sir i applaud you for
recommending campaign involvement to
your audience but i really caution
against sending uh sending excess time
and donations to marcus flowers campaign
i worry too many progressives will make
the same mistake
they made with the amy mcgrath campaign
in 2020 out of a passion to oust mitch
mcconnell only to see her lose big time
instead i would recommend efforts going
towards flippable races tim ryan in ohio
beasley in north carolina fetterman and
pennsylvania and defending vulnerable
incumbents spanberger in virginia and
slotkin in michigan the truth there
simply aren't enough democratic voters
to oust green something something i
obviously want to see happen someday
in that district and the primary numbers
from wednesday reflect that in my
judgment it's better to keep green and
the minority then naively assume
we can remove her at this time this is a
completely fair point i'm never going to
say
ignore this race okay
but it is absolutely true that the
numbers in marjory taylor green's
district make it hard to believe that in
such a red district the non-incumbent
democratic nominee uh flowers
is going to be able to win
now i'm not saying ignore the race but
we do have limited resources and i think
samuel makes an important point here
about understanding how to best use
those admittedly limited resources
keep it in mind
uh okay hannah wrote in and says
recession soon hi david i'm hearing more
news stories that say the us is
barreling toward recession right now and
that this recession will start within
the next year do you agree why or why
not thank you hannah here's the
difficulty of this question
we may already be in a recession we may
be getting out of it right now we you
know
everybody defines it differently
understand that for a decade many have
been saying a recession is imminent
uh around 2015 there were lots of people
saying a recession is imminent imagine
if you had listened to them in 2015 and
said i believe the recession is imminent
i'm getting out of the stock market you
would have missed one of the greatest
run-ups in the stock market in decades
so my view is i don't know if a
recession is coming i can't control
whether a recession is coming at some
point there will be another recession
what do i know well i know my principles
i know that my principle is asset
allocation and my principle is low-cost
index funds without trying to time the
market and my principle is when the
market goes down
those same index fund purchases get me
more shares at a lower price because i
can't time it i don't know whether a
recession is coming and so i think a lot
of times the right question to ask is if
a recession were coming what what would
i do or what would i do differently
for most people the answer is well
actually nothing i wouldn't do anything
differently so i don't have the answer
uh about a recession but what i do have
is a plan
that is the plan whether or not we are
in a recession i hope that makes sense
niels wrote in with an idea for uh when
we get to 1.5 million youtube
subscribers and neil says hi david on
achieving 1.5 million subscribers may i
suggest you receive a colonoscopy on air
so
the joke here is recently someone wrote
in and said david you should do a
colonoscopy when you get to 1.5 million
subscribers and the wording was funny
because typically it's the doctors doing
the the uh colonoscopy and it's the
patients receiving so i was like are you
saying that i should receive one or that
i should perform one
niels is clarifying that and saying i
should receive the colonoscopy when i
get to 1.5 million subscribers well
that's something we will look into okay
uh lucas has a different idea
lucas says hello david love your show
i've been watching the last two years
now watching your show reading
suggestions for what to do for 1.5
million on youtube i think you should
eat a carolina reaper it is the world's
hottest pepper and i feel like it would
gather a lot of attention to your
channel you should also set a date for
when you want to hit it in order to eat
the pepper i'm just going to pass on
that i am not interested in hot peppers
uh i mean listen
i love a good jalapeno
i'll use fresno chilies and cooking
dried thai chilies serrano for a
beautiful coconut cod chowder that i
like to make you chop up a serrano
pepper it's beautiful smoky heat
but i don't like stunts like this i
don't like eating contests and i have no
this is a no this is a hard no i would
sooner bleacher my hair or shave my head
than uh than do do this stacy wrote in
does a fetus have a right to get child
support
hi
if life begins at conception
shouldn't child support start at
conception yours stacy i've brought this
up many times before
um
the issue
about personhood at conception raises
really important questions
um
if a fetus is a citizen a facility if a
fetus is a person at conception
then it is a citizen right i mean it
should be able to be made a citizen
and even if it's the fetus of an
undocumented immigrant they should be
able to get citizenship
after conception because if it's a
person people get citizenship
if it is a person at conception
then presumably it would be entitled to
child support as well
uh it i mean listen
good luck actually having rational
conversations about these things with
the anti-choice movement but of course
stacy brings up a good point which is
it's less about when do we say life has
started
forms of life exist in so many places
and in so many ways and a fetus is less
about whether it qualifies as quote life
but
what is a person and what are the rights
that come with personhood because the
anti-choice movement wants to talk a lot
about specific rights that they believe
a fetus should have
but not about
many of the others that people
persons
also get
and it's an age-old hypocrisy as long as
roe v wade has been around all of these
arguments have been around and sadly
they very often become philosophical
black holes and you don't get anywhere
with them but an important question
info davidpakman.com if you have
questions comments suggestions that you
would like featured in the weekly
mailbag make sure that you are signed up
at
joinpackman.com get a membership get the
bonus show and get the commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
every day six hours before
they are published to everybody
joinpacman.com is the place to sign up